[Music]
Rice. A simple word, yet it represents a
dietary cornerstone for billions around
the globe. From Asia to Africa and from
the Americas to Europe, rice is a
fundamental part of daily meals. This
humble grain in all its varieties graces
tables from bustling cities to remote
villages. Whether it's sushi in Japan,
biryani in India, or jambalaya in the
southern United States, rice is a
versatile ingredient that adapts to
countless culinary traditions. But have
you ever stopped to think about the
journey rice takes from tiny seed to
your plate? It's a fascinating process
that involves meticulous planning and
hard work. One crucial stage in this
journey is rice transplanting. This step
is vital for ensuring that the rice
plants have enough space to grow and
access to the nutrients they need. This
age-old practice passed down through
generations of farmers plays a pivotal
role in ensuring a healthy and bountiful
rice harvest. It's a tradition that
connects the past with the present, and
it requires skill and dedication. It's a
process that demands patience, care, and
a deep understanding of the land.
Farmers must be attuned to the subtle
changes in the environment to ensure the
best possible yield. Whether you're a
seasoned farmer or a curious beginner,
this guide will equip you with the
knowledge to master the art of rice
transplanting. You'll learn about the
best times to transplant, the ideal
conditions for growth, and the
techniques that have been honed over
centuries. So, let's dive in and explore
the fascinating world of rice
cultivation. From the science behind the
soil to the art of planting, there's so
much to discover and appreciate about
this staple
crop. Rice transplanting is exactly what
it sounds like. Carefully moving young
rice plants or seedlings from a nursery
bed to a larger field. Think of it like
giving your rice plants more room to
grow. Why is this necessary? Initially,
rice seeds are sewn in a smaller
controlled environment, the nursery bed.
This allows them to germinate and
develop strong roots without competition
from weeds. Once the seedlings are big
enough, they need more space and
nutrients to thrive. That's where
transplanting comes in. By carefully
moving them to the main field, we give
them the best chance to flourish and
produce a bountiful
harvest. Timing is crucial in
agriculture, and rice transplanting is
no exception. Transplanting at the right
time can significantly impact the health
and yield of your rice crop. The ideal
time typically falls within 20 to 30
days after sewing the seeds in the
nursery. By this time, the seedlings
should have developed 3 to four leaves
and a healthy root system. However,
remember that weather and local
conditions play a role. Consulting with
experienced farmers in your area can
provide valuable insights on the optimal
transplanting window for your region.
Factors like rainfall patterns,
temperature, and soil moisture should
all be
considered. Before welcoming the young
rice seedlings, the main field needs to
be prepped and ready to receive them.
This involves several important steps to
ensure the soil is fertile and
weed-free. First, the field is plowed
and harrowed to break up the soil,
improving its texture and irerration.
This also helps to incorporate organic
matter and fertilizers into the soil,
providing essential nutrients for the
growing plants. Next, the field is
flooded with water. This creates the
iconic patty field environment that rice
thrives in. The water helps to control
weeds, regulate temperature, and provide
moisture to the plants. Finally, the
field is leveled to ensure an even water
depth throughout. This is essential for
uniform plant growth and easier
management. Section five, the main act,
transplanting techniques. Now comes the
main event, carefully transplanting the
rice seedlings into their new home.
There are two primary methods for this.
Manual transplanting and machine
transplanting. Manual transplanting, as
the name suggests, involves
transplanting the seedlings by hand.
This laborintensive method has been
practiced for centuries and is still
common in many parts of the world.
Machine transplanting, on the other
hand, uses specialized equipment to
transplant the seedlings. This method is
faster and less labor intensive, making
it suitable for larger farms. Regardless
of the method, the key is to transplant
the seedlings at the correct depth,
spacing them evenly to avoid
overcrowding. This ensures each plant
has adequate space, nutrients, and
sunlight to
[Music]
flourish. Section six, nurturing growth
post-rplanting care. After the hard work
of transplanting, it's time to focus on
nurturing the young rice plants as they
adapt to their new environment. This
period is critical as the plants are
vulnerable and need extra care to
establish themselves. Proper afterare is
crucial for ensuring their healthy
growth and development. This involves a
combination of water management,
nutrient supply, and protection from
pests and diseases. One of the most
important aspects of post-rplant care is
maintaining the water level in the
field. Water management is essential to
provide the right conditions for the
rice plants to thrive. Rice plants need
a constant supply of water, especially
during the early stages of growth.
Ensuring that the water level is neither
too high nor too low is key to
preventing stress on the plants. Regular
monitoring of water levels is essential.
adjusting them as needed to create the
optimal conditions for the plants. This
helps in avoiding water stress and
ensures that the plants have enough
moisture to support their growth. Too
much water can lead to root rot while
too little can stunt growth. It's a
delicate balance that requires careful
attention and timely adjustments.
Fertilization is another vital aspect of
post-rplant care. Providing the right
nutrients at the right time can
significantly impact the health and
yield of the rice plants. Rice plants
require a steady supply of nutrients,
including nitrogen, phosphorus, and
potassium. These nutrients support
various growth stages and help the
plants develop strong roots and healthy
foliage. Timely fertilizer application
ensures they have everything they need
to thrive. Regularly checking the
nutrient levels in the soil and
adjusting the fertilizer application
accordingly can lead to a bountiful
harvest. Section seven, reaping the
rewards. Benefits of proper
transplanting. Proper rice transplanting
offers numerous benefits leading to
healthier plants, higher yields, and a
more efficient farming process. When
done correctly, transplanting can
significantly impact the overall success
of a rice crop, ensuring that each plant
has the best possible start. Let's
explore some of these advantages in more
detail. One of the most significant
benefits is improved plant
establishment. When seedlings are
transplanted, they are given the
opportunity to develop a robust root
system in a controlled environment
before being moved to the field.
Transplanting allows for better root
development and stronger plants, making
them more resilient to pests, diseases,
and environmental stress. This
resilience is crucial for maintaining a
healthy crop throughout the growing
season. Uniform plant growth is another
advantage. By ensuring that each plant
is spaced evenly, we can maximize the
use of available resources. By
transplanting at consistent depths and
spacing, we ensure that all plants
receive adequate sunlight, nutrients,
and water, leading to a more uniform and
productive field. This uniformity not
only improves the overall health of the
crop, but also simplifies management
practices. Weed control is also more
manageable in transplanted rice. With
proper spacing, it becomes easier to
identify and remove weeds, reducing
competition for resources. By preparing
the field thoroughly before
transplanting, we can significantly
reduce weed pressure, giving our rice
plants a head start. This preparation
includes leveling the field, ensuring
proper water management, and creating an
ideal environment for the young plants
to
thrive. Section 8. Conclusion: Happy
Transplanting. As you've learned, rice
transplanting is a crucial stage in the
journey from seed to plate. It's a
process that demands attention to
detail, care, and a deep understanding
of the needs of this vital crop.
Remember, practice makes perfect. Don't
be afraid to experiment, learn from your
experiences, and seek advice from
experienced farmers in your area. With
patience and dedication, you too can
master the art of rice transplanting,
and enjoy the rewards of a bountiful
harvest. So go forth and plant with
confidence, and may your rice fields
forever be lush, green, and overflowing
with the promise of a plentiful harvest.